this week on quad Riga getting involved
German arms for Iraq Germany wants to
send weapons to Kurdish forces in
northern Iraq pressure has mounted on
Berlin to move beyond humanitarian aid
and to assist Iraqis under assault from
the Islamic state hundreds of thousands
have been displaced Germany's foreign
and defense ministers say they will
closely coordinate with the EU as they
move ahead with France and Britain are
already supplying weapons to Kurdish
fighters but sending arms of any kind to
a war zone is controversial and
generally prohibited by German law not
least because those weapons could later
end up in the wrong hands a watershed
moment in German politics ken German
weapons help stop the Sunni insurgency
or could they fuel a future conflict
your host this week alyas lon hello and
welcome to a new edition of quadriga
while the german government has finally
made a decision whether or not to supply
the curtain northern iraq with arms and
the answer is yes it will what
repercussions will this decision have on
the conflict and could the decision
perhaps even backfire that those are the
questions I'm going to talk about on
today show together with three experts
all who've been following the story very
closely so I'm very happy to welcome to
the show Michael Shermer who's the
senior correspondent at the German daily
de Velde he's a renowned historian and a
specialist on foreign affairs and
security issues Boca bilqis is a
political editor and presenter at the
german at germany's public broadcasting
radio network Deutschland radio
previously he reported as a foreign
correspondent from Washington Brussels
London and Paris and Christine hey Beck
is a journalist covering international
relations with the focus on the Middle
East for most of the past decade she was
posted as a foreign correspondent in the
Syrian capital Damascus
mukesh doma the decision has finally
been made the decision that the
political leadership in Germany has been
agonizing over for the better part of
the summer now it's clear the German
government will provide weapons to
Kurdish Peshmerga in northern Iraq to
help them in their fight against the
so-called Islamic state is this the
right decision well first of all my
question is what weapons we are not
supplying tanks guns we are supplying
all kinds of equipment some of this we
haven't even got so it will be a very
modest contribution and on the
battlefield it will not make a sizeable
difference it is more moral decision and
it recognizes that these terrible events
in the Middle East may have something to
do with our own interests and our own
security so it's more in on the
psychological and strategic level then
on the actual equation dynamics on the
battlefield so but do you welcome the
decision I think it was high time and it
was an undignified drama that we saw
first no never will not do anything
which correspondent of course to the
vast majority of the German seventy-four
percent say nothing for us this is
officer on a different planet the bet
the other side of the moon while the
government then took the courageous
decision which is probably not being
welcomed by the majority of the gems
indeed it's not and we'll talk about
that in just a moment but Christine
Arabic so the decision has been made and
clearly the German Foreign Minister Shen
Maya as well as the defense secretary of
defense fund a line have said yes this
is the right decision for Germany to get
involved do you agree I agree but I
would say that it's not only about
arming the Kurdish Peshmerga we have to
be careful because it's not the Kurdish
Peshmerga that will finish up with the
Islamic state Islamic state is trying to
build up a Caliphate over
national borders we should stop thinking
in national borders in national
nation-states so we have to think
further on and I don't say that we have
to engage militarily very much
personally and actively from the West I
would say we should do as less as little
as possible to engage ourselves we have
to learn our lessons from george w bush
the invasion in iraq which is to a great
extent responsible for the rise of the
Islamic state if we go back in history
in the last decade so we have to be
careful we have to do as little as
possible militarily to engage ourselves
but we have to look for our partners in
the region the armed groups in the
region who are confronting the Islamic
state these are not only the Peshmerga
but that sounds more like the old german
foreign policy in the sense let the
other ones do the fighting and we'll sit
back and perhaps no no we should arm
them we should we should support them
with everything they need for this fight
against the Islamic state but it's not
the West so should solve this because
it's the West who is responsible with
other factors for the rise of the
Islamic state and boycott be ok now the
decision has to be made whether
Parliament the German parliament has to
actually approve this decision made by
the political leadership they are
various voices out there who say yes of
course parliament has to be involved
others say not so much this very much is
an emergency state therefore we can
decide on our own what's your take
personally I'd welcome if the Parliament
had to say in this because it's a
fundamental switch and change of german
foreign policy i mean we are sort of
taking more responsibility we can look
at what president GAO said already at
the security conference in munich saying
that germany needs to be more present
and needs to show more presence on the
international scene take up its
responsibility we have a human Therrien
catastrophe with the refugees in
northern iraq so that might be a reason
for delivering arms which is actually
strictly speaking in the sense of the
letter of the law against our rules but
you can make an exception to the rule
but as long as we deliver weapons to
Saudi Arabia to Qatar to all these
states who
in one way or another mangling in this
conflict supporting do indirectly or
directly the Islamic state then we
should also give weapons to to the Kurds
in this case to stop this humanitarian
catastrophe but we need to rethink
generally our weapons export policy and
we should have the Parliament have a say
in this because it's a fundamental
change it is a change and as you've
already mentioned it is also against the
law strictly speaking because the German
law Constitution forbids arm deliveries
to war zones and crying carries no the
German constitution says we should not
engage in aggressive war that is a very
big difference the German constitution
isn't so particular it doesn't say you
can deliver Red Cross material but you
cannot send guns no no but it's very
clear that no crisis area is supposed to
receive German weapons as long as there
are exceptions and in this case actually
formally the German government needs to
ask the Iraqi government if they are
allowed to deliver the weapons to the
Kurds I don't know if they really going
to do that there is an absurdity the
whole thing because we are we have
restricted ourselves not delivering web
selling weapons to 10 total attention
afflicted areas now where else do you
need weapons it's a bit absurd and this
absurdity has survived for a long time
and now the world is a flame in many
places and we have to consider our own
interests this is always presented as a
moral decision for me it is right also a
moral decision but above all it's a
decision which we have to find according
to our interests and this is not
somewhere as I said on the other side of
the moon this is pretty close this is on
the threshold of Europe and what happens
today in Syria or what used to be Syria
can happen the day after tomorrow
in European capitals David Cameron just
came out with the statement which I
found very strong where he said we may
face those guns the Qaeda guns in our
capitals Christine havoc yes but I think
we have to make very something very
clear I think the only reason to
intervene militarily from any other
foreign state is responsibility to
protect now this is about saving lives
this is about rescuing civilians who are
under acute threat from the Islamic
state this is not about political
interests this is not about economic
interest it's not even about our values
I don't think that we should send
weapons or anything else in the region
for our values our interests it comes
together with this i agree with you
eaten in the end it is in our interest
because these terrorists it's my goal I
mean they might blow a bomb in any
European selecting a differentiation yes
but the international law has this
principal responsibility to protect and
this should be the only reason and this
should be the only measure that we
consider in such a situation do we save
civilian lives or not and then of course
we can not only think about northern
Iraq then we have to think about Syria
but it's a dangerous step to do anyway
because just imagine the Kurds taken up
these weapons in a couple of years
against turkey because they want to have
their own Kurdistan their state and they
turn this weapon against the NATO
partner of Germany so we have seen the
same scenario in the 90s when the Reagan
administration gave weapons to the
Mujahideen and we all know what happened
ten years later or 11 years later after
nine eleven so we have to consider the
dangers of such a such a decision this
is exactly what I'm saying this is the
big difference in Afghanistan it was
about political interest it was about
the big cold war against it against
Russian deck against the Soviet Union
now it's only about civilian sitting
there on the top of the hills they need
to be rescued so this is the
responsibility protect is really a new
fundamental principle of international
law and where if not in Iraq in Syria we
should apply it and the fear that the
weapons could fall into the wrong hands
is very real and we look at the example
of Libya where French weapons ended up
in Mali and certainly now our call
in great deal of the stress in Libya
itself of course there's talk that the
is Islamic state themselves ceased us
weapons from the Iraqi army so Mukesh
Emma do you see do you see you know the
the the danger that German weapons will
fall into the wrong hands eventually
well first of all what weapons and how
many I don't I don't really think that
that would make much of a difference
whatever we do now and I agree
responsibility to protect is at least
United Nations consensus we are we are
we are having some kind of firm ground
in international law and let us use that
i would add of course that the question
of national interest national security
comes in and that for me is at least
fifty percent of the decision and i
agree with the decision of course you
never know where it ends up one of the
people who were supported in Afghanistan
against the soviets was osama bin laden
he learned the trade of killing in the
mountains of Afghanistan and of course
he also perhaps not personally but his
gang use American high class weaponry
and woke up I guess some even say the
move not just of course on the part of
Germany to supply weapons but the EU in
general you foreign ministers have all
approved this move by the way what
haston and speeding up the
disintegration of the State of Iraq do
you see the danger here well what is
that it is integrated it's a it is
already disintegrated and you have to
have a Canton ization also i don't think
the the EVOC rocky state is going to
continue in the future as one state as
one nation I don't see this and actually
we already do have an independent or
partially independent Kurdistan in the
north I don't think the shy and then at
the Sunnis will ever get peacefully
together even with this new head of
government I really don't see this I
mean this whole place is a mess and
actually mess that goes back to the
colonial times when
pecos sykes line was drawn up against
all ethnic against all a sense of
religious respect and so this goes back
a long time this goes back a long time
and the other problem we have here
Kristin how big is that the Kurtz
themselves in northern Iraq are not
unified in fact the PKK has already come
out against the move to supply weapons
to the Kurdish Peshmerga northern Iraq
led by barzani bit of a mess no it's
very complicated I mean we should really
hope that at least the Kurds among
themselves would unify in this fight and
that it's not a valentino food I haven't
done so but there are some some positive
steps here what is important is that we
don't draw a further split between the
Kurds and the Arabs this is very
important because we have a lot of
hatred growing between the two ethnics
we have a lot of problems between Arabs
and Kurds not only in Iraq but
especially in Syria so what is important
for me is to create a unified front
against the Islamic state and who is the
most important part in this destinies of
the region who will win against the
Islamic state not the Kurds not the
ship's the ones who have to win against
the Islamic state are the Sunnis because
they have the the tools ideologically to
confront this group to say this is not
Islam this is not what we want we don't
want to be head people this is not our
form of living the Islam so we have to
create one unified front against the
Islamic state with all the religious and
professional groups in the region and
all the ethnics so I think we should
support the efforts of Kurds and Arabs
to unify and maybe we should even put
conditions on sending arms if you have
among your soldiers Arabs and Christians
and Yazidis and whoever is in this
region especially in Syria there is a
big responsibility to and have some
efforts in unifying the rebels against
this Islamic state we have a lot of
different rupes who fight the Islamic
state and there should be some kind of a
yes an effort from outside to help them
unify in this do we have the
intellectual capacity and the material
capacity to for remote control managing
the this terrible control the groups
identified i mean the the moderate
rebels in syria the file against remote
control from belen no washing no but we
have our partners in the region we are
supposed to talk to them and to convince
them of some steps and to just I mean we
are supposed to just help and support
initiatives that are already there it's
not the politics politics must take the
lead politics or in the region yes but
without telling them what to do but just
to find the people in this region who
act in this way of thinking you're on it
isn't you need to get the protector
powers into the boat as we say in German
I mean you need to get turkey with
supporting some Sunni groups you need to
get Saudi Arabia you need to get Qatar
and Iran supporting the Shiites you need
to get those powers around the table and
negotiate and make their influence
really is strong on these groups that
are fighting on the ground because there
and they are all supporting the groups
that are fighting Islamic exactly that's
why you and we the Germans the you the
United States need to make put pressure
on Turkey on Saudi Arabia me that's what
drives me crazy why are we delivering
lots of weapons to Saudi Arabian at the
same time there is evidence that Saudi
Arabian people are supporting this
Islamic state but this is really wrong
this this is really it's a lot of times
people get this wrong it's not the state
of Saudi Arabia the liberal in Saudi
Arabia people join Arabia this is not a
policy of the Saudi government we are
delivering ants to Saudi government I'm
completely against lives in iran saudi
arabia this is another on the side of
commitment sorry i did not say the
government rate of the Islamic state
they're all afraid of al-qaeda in the
first place yeah nor the Saudis nor the
catteries have any interest in these
jihadi movements in the region they are
completely against it who the Saudis are
financing inside Syria Islamic groups
Syrian Islamists while finding against
Bashar al-assad men were finding at the
same time on the second front against
the Islamic state in the south
especially this is the Islamic Front in
Syria Islamic Front other Syrian
Islamists finding against Bashar Assad
and taking up arms against the Islamic
state this is the Saudi allies in Syria
but so this is they are already finding
the people who stand up against the
Islamic
but we have to that's I completely agree
we have to come together to prepare to
put pressure and to talk to these states
who have a vital interest and of course
if we look at the numbers Mukesh them
has already mentioned them more than
seventy percent of germans opposed this
move they don't want any German arms to
be supplied to northern Iraq or else
fear that's where for that matter i mean
the the they prefer military restraint
this is more or less the part the
thinking on the part of the Germans is
it an outdated thinking or do you think
it's it yeah understandable it's
understandable and my generation was the
post-war generation was raised in this
culpability complex and we have done all
this horror in the Second World War we
have initiated all we were majorly
involved in two world wars and so
Germany should abstain but I mean when
the humanitarian catastrophes and there
are people who need to be protected and
I think Germany needs to take up more
responsibility there i agree with you
are in Gaul co-president whoo-hoo limits
this idea though to humanitarian things
and we need to take up more
responsibility the world and Europe
expects this from Germany but that's why
I said at the beginning we need the
Parliament to agree because if you say
seventy percent of the people disagree
who represents the people in the
parliament it's the deputies it's our
Bundestag so they should have a load and
a say in this yeah but I think we
isolated ourselves when then Great
Britain and France and the u.s. decided
to at least two to have air strikes on
Libya at the time and Germany ever since
men was very isolated on the
international scene and I think what we
are seeing now with our foreign minister
and our defense minister they want a
shift they want Germany to take up its
responsibilities that the others expect
from us and mahesh toma the figure of
seventy percent of germans oppose stance
somewhat in stark contrast to the other
figure namely that germany is the third
largest arms exporter in the world after
the US and Russia in fact it has made
revenues on sales are the reason for
news of 8 billion euros just last year
alone so my question is this seems to be
discrepancy between what the people want
and what is actually happening on the
ground the people want the cake and eat
it want to have the cake and eat it of
course flourishing exports whatever and
the differentiation between arms and
non-lethal arms and lethal arns is very
complex and open to interpretation so
yeah it's the normal human saying have
the cake and eat it and also I don't
think that the government and Parliament
as a whole because the parliament has
also the key responsibility has always
had it has claimed it and hasn't
exercised because with the
responsibility go go's leadership and
the German public I think was troubled
by the tooling and throwing of the
government over the last few weeks there
was no leadership not from the top and
not from the ranks of the foreign
secretary and the defense secretary so
that's the normal response if people are
not presented with a with a strong
element of reasoning and from time to
time a glance at the map this is all
very close and we this doesn't happen
elsewhere if this happens this this has
enormous repercussions for life in our
cities so like three million tracks of
German leadership here a lack of
leadership in Germany translates into
lack of German leadership and there is a
lot of work to be done and a lot of
arguments to be exchanged and a lot of
guidance to be given I mean I understand
all these Germans I completely agree
with the with the sentence that arms
cannot solve political problems and that
you know the the world is full of arms
we don't eat more arms these are all
sentenced that everybody sentences that
we would all like to agree i think the
Germans are just the
used to this kind of policy that you
have sometimes to engage even militarily
and I mean this sentence that we have
heard from a lot of German politicians
that we have already enough arms in the
region we don't need more arms to solve
the problem it's very cynical for any
Iraqi and Syrian in the region because
who has the arms the arms are right now
in the wrong hands of course Bashar
al-assad a theory has everything he
needs barrel bombs and what have you to
kill civilians in aleppo and all the
major cities of syria and of course
islamic state had everything they've
dreamed off since they took muscle and
they have all this modern american
military equipment so who has the arms
right now can we say oh is everything
there so let's just lay back and leave
the civilians to these brutal forces now
they are in the wrong hands and this is
why not delivering arms means we don't
stay neutral we don't stay out of the
game you know we're just objective no we
take sides of the stronger of the ones
who have the arm so this is why taking
up on your new point I mean lettuce
Assad get its weapons from Russia so
that's another point why we need to
negotiate with Russia also what the
Ukrainian conflict is concerned so I
mean we need Russia in the boat I mean
we're in the post-cold war area and I
mean sometimes I miss the stability we
had them the Cold War because the front
lines were very clear but now they're
very dirty games being played here going
back to the cold water yeah we're
actually going back to a cold war time
yeah so we really need to get Russia
stability but I was just going exactly
yeah well fine it added price but it
also presented gave stability so we need
a two-fold strategy here then if I
understand you correctly supply arms but
also talk to the countries that are
fueling these proxy wars that absolutely
you need a political solution for Iraq I
mean the Americans have left a mess but
they're not the only ones who are
responsible for this mess even though
the invasion was in my opinion
completely wrong and nuts and but I mean
the conflicts were there before I mean
it was not that Sunni and Shiites were
living and peaceful happily ever
together no we were living together
quite happily so somehow the same was
sort of yeah it's a dictatorship and
under the dictatorship of course
everybody was people were not focused on
the world and people would marry in
among
Sunnis and Shias what it was quite
normal you know I mean the amongst
Americans the two major mistakes they
dissolved the army they dissolved the
bath party then they thought that their
own soldiers would you know control the
this made them occupiers and they left
all these soldiers and party leaders
without a job so they're all engaged
against the US occupation so this is
this is this created a Qaeda in Iraq but
i think the hatred is so big that I
can't imagine the Iraqi people living
together in one nation state at least
you have a very federal system with very
regional autonomy for forum in Kurdistan
is already autonomous but you have maybe
a Shiite region or a Sunni region I
think that's the only way you can happen
you could even expand this over to some
Syrian people gives the Kurds in Syria
would probably much rather live with the
people the Kurds from northern Iraq then
Syria looking at the current state of
your rocket is indeed very hard to
imagine how this country is going to
move forward as a unifying territory
from now on Germany as we said third
largest arms exporter in the world sixty
percent more than sixty percent of these
arms go to countries outside of the EU
and NATO mainly to countries like
already been said Saudi Arabia to Qatar
Algeria it's right it's one of them
Israel also that's the question that is
there a strategy behind this is it or is
this are these arms sales randomly being
being taken place because why not for
instance supply Ukraine with arms then
it's a law of supply and demand to
supply Ukraine I think would be very
foolish and highly dangerous with
weapons because this would be hostile
act towards Russia and I think we've
plenty of hostile acts against Russia
without having to add weapons for
Ukraine so the pick and choose strategy
then there is no major strategy behind
it it's the marketplace
and of course some particular unsavory
regimes don't get the best weapons but
on the whole this figure of I think five
billion euros 88 build it well it isn't
all that much the budgets the defense
budgets are the world are a mountain and
this is molehill I'm not belittling it
but this doesn't make much of a
difference the Soviets or the Russians
the poster with Russians and Americans
are filling the Arsenal's left and right
what we are doing is to a large extent
of course NATO and EU and otherwise much
of this has been stopped and they were
in recent weeks and months and from the
looks of it it will be stopped even
further if we can believe vice
chancellor and economic minister sigma
Gabrielle who made it very clear
Germany's Vice Chancellor that he wants
to restrict the sale of arms which of
course now has the arms industry up in
arms and this looking at the
seventy-four percent Wow and he is not
listening to the Iggy metal the trade
unions but this is the discussion i mean
the decision to supply curtain northern
iraq with arms the timing is rather
peculiar because it coincides with
another debate going on in germany right
now namely to do exactly the opposite to
restrict arms sales from the correct
because it's actually a contradiction
because on the one hand our Vice
Chancellor Sigma Gabrielle from the
Social Democrats are saying actually we
should really focus on our arms export
only to two nations who are blah secure
respecting human rights and he wants to
actually restrict the arms export and at
the same time you have this decision of
supplying arms to the Kurds but you have
to distinguish one is an emergency
situation in humanitarian crisis where
Germany has to take up its
responsibility and the other one is the
general direction of our arms sales and
I think Sigma Capulets completely right
and rethinking our strategy of exporting
I mean our tanks little part to Saudi
Arabia to Qatar because these are not
following our standards states that
Nessus
respect human rights as we expect
nations to do and we're talking about an
industry who employs roughly a hundred
thousand people in Germany directly and
I think all over 350,000 jobs depend on
it of course there is an economic
argument yeah you might lose some jobs
but what is it worth it I mean to stand
up for our values to protect human
rights and maybe lose some jobs I think
it's worth it well a clear statement
mukesh sharma would you agree with the
vice-chancellor than with my god yes and
Eamon the question there are many
questions in the devil is always in the
detail and I'm I don't i think gabrielle
is doing the is arguing in a way that of
course is in the line of argument of the
SPD Steinmeier of course has other
concerns as a foreign minister and we'll
see what comes out so far what we are
delivering to the Kurds what we have to
give them deliver them sell them
probably not sell is almost
insignificant in military terms it's
more moral question a question of
principle and as we said in the
beginning of this program it is a break
with the past but not all that radical
we've moved slowly consciously half
consciously not unconsciously in that
direction and of course responsibility
to protect is their responsibility to
protect is a very dangerous element it
is it was celebrated when it was
introduced in the United Nations a few
years ago and as a long debate and an
honorable debate in which many good
people have taken part but what if Putin
says tomorrow or even today or yesterday
I have the responsibility to protect my
fellow Russians who are under
terrible stress in Ukraine weather is
where there is suppression of the
Russian language and all kinds of
horrible things that's the dilemma that
legacy because with the same argument
that the United States is bombing Isis
in northern Iraq I mean booting could
say well I forget I have to go in to
eastern Ukraine to protect the people
there because they're being slaughtered
by the Ukrainian army so and Putin and
the Russian government are using this
argument I mean they're always referring
to to the NATO intervention in Kosovo in
against Serbia at the time in the 90s so
without the United Nations and hand it
so that is why and the united nations
have been mentioned here I mean this is
why we need to get the united nations
involved and maybe convince Russia of
course Russia has the right to veto
there but I mean we need to get the
united nations involved in a solution
for these crisis because they never make
a shimmer doesn't seem to think that
German weapons in northern Iraq will
make any difference that's just a true
because the Americans are delivering a
lot more and so it doesn't make this
much of a difference if the Germans
deliver or not or the French I mean
depending on what exactly we deliver I
agree but I think and I mean we cannot
compare what's happening in the Ukraine
with what Bashar Assad is doing to his
people excuse me I mean we are talking
about a clog other the argument I know
yes we should go there and yes but I
mean we add we are talking about
genocide usually the responsibility
project to protect comes in a situation
where a government is not able to
protect its own people now in Syria it's
not the government who is not able to
protect its the government itself who is
killing its people so this is really
general side and this is really a way of
this is really a case for responsibility
project to protect we engaged the NATO
engaged in Libya where Gaddafi was about
to commit eventually a genocide you know
and we intervene now in northern Iraq
it's not the Iraqi state I mean is the
rocky state who is not able to protect
its people that's true so this would be
the case for responsibility to protect
but I think we have to look very
carefully in the in the
faces and if Russia now says you know we
have to protect our fellow Russians in
any it's not comparable I think very
fine the argument is being used because
I mean if you talk to Russians
hardliners or if you talk to some people
on the pro-russian rebels there they say
our civilians are being attacked by the
Ukrainian army they're terrorizing us so
let's cry for help so going back to the
United Nations I mean it's I completely
agree that we usually should get the
United Nations in the boat and they are
the ones who should take the big
decision and the Security Council is the
the place to take such a decision but
again coming back to Syria the United
Nations and the Security Council has
completely failed the role of the
Security Council is ridiculous and it's
a shame it's changeful actually if you
look at the serum couldn't we think of a
human manatorian corridor northern Iraq
for instance decided by the United
Nations yes and then we sent the Yazidis
to put a safe corridor to Syria and then
in Syria we let them if we let them down
towards the Islamic state the Islamic
state has its basis in raka for over a
year this is the provincial capital in
Syria raka they are taking control over
there is oh they are standing in the
front of Aleppo we have a very loud cry
for help from the head of the civilian
counts of the Civil Council of Aleppo
whose ass who's crying for help the
Americans and say where are you they are
about to Assad regime has put a seat on
Aleppo now the Islamic state is coming
from the other side to Aleppo a leper
will be finished in a couple of weeks if
we don't do anything you know I mean
it's hundreds of thousands who are
already living under the rule of the
Islamic state inside Syria so I am now
not arguing implicitly for boots on the
ground no I'm completely against boots
on the ground speak off we have the
groups there the local groups who stand
up against the Islamic state they are
all identified because they receive some
little help from the Americans but it's
not enough they have to upgrade their
military help and very quickly because
otherwise we lose the fight against the
Islamic state we cannot win it in Iraq
lose a little too late it's not too late
not too late not yet well troubling
times anyway I think we can agree
the troubling times all around and look
at Becca the decision to supply Kurt
with arms with German arms it comes at a
time again at a very interesting time
because so much has been made of the
terms new German responsibility you know
it was put forth by President GOG it was
put forth by foreign minister Steinmeier
defense minister if on the line the new
German responsibilities is this a litmus
test here and northern Iraq if Germany
is really willing to to follow through
with what is the first step towards a
new policy and to put it bluntly I mean
my church tumor has mentioned it before
but I mean I'm actually missing
leadership by my Chancellor she she
she's always with her famous way of
reacting at the last moment I mean she
was really being pushed by a minister of
defense and by Amir foreign minister
because at the beginning of last week
the official wording was no weapons into
this crisis area and towards the middle
of the week yes we think about it and
all of a sudden we delivered so i
actually am doubting the leadership
capacity for angular nagaland this isn't
other fields as well and the financial
crisis she's always been being pushed by
sarkozy at the time the french president
and she's always taken the decisions at
this last possible moment to avoid some
deep damage and and what I'm missing is
leadership in this case really
leadership and say okay we have this
responsibility not only for these arms
deliveries for internationally we have
to stand up more for what we are
economically a big country powerful and
the Americans and other suspect expect
Germany to have the leadership role in
Europe and unfortunately the French our
partner due to their economical and
financial problems they are not as
strong as they used to be because gemma
is this decision a watershed moment and
german foreign policy are we indeed
seeing a new german for importance it's
not to turn around but it's a watershed
moment yes I would agree there's one
point which I would like to mention when
you talk about weapons whatever kind of
weapons and whatever quantities and
quality
the Kurds the vast majority of Kurds
live in today's Turkey we are talking
about the Kurdish quasi-state in the
north of Iraq and we also talk we are
not talking about the seven million
Kurds in Iran and Iran will be very very
inimical to any kind of Kurdish State
emerging so this needs a kind of
fine-tuning and this is far beyond the
kind of leadership that Berlin has shown
or even Washington has shown there is a
new crisis brewing next year the year
after next because of this Kurdish
problem which has been not been resolved
for at least a century but which is
important here i think is the other one
government has very strong economic ties
with northern Iraq they have very strong
political ties to the leadership to
masoud barzani the head of the
autonomous region in northern Iraq it's
a de facto state already in northern
Iraq would we see there everyone doesn't
have a problem for this de facto state
it's behind the mountains and he was
wise enough enough to engage with this
government he has a problem with the
peacock a and he has a problem with the
PYD which is the peacock a sister party
in inside Syria so Aragon does have a
problem if we say ok we will not armed
only the pesh MERGA in northern Iraq
let's go and deliver arms to the PYD
because they are defending Kurdish
cities like Qamishli or other smaller
villages in northern Syria against the
Islamic state I mean the PYD would be
one of the groups inside Syria who
should be supported against the Islamic
state this is where other one will have
a problem the UN is complicated it is
complicated for certain in the US and
other EU partners at you already
mentioned have asked me to grow up if
you will to assume its responsibilities
on the world stage not just economically
but also in crises like this again is
this a new german foreign policy we're
seeing emerging we've seen it emerging
and i think we are living a very very
interesting moment of how this foreign
policy is being shaped
but it's a process it's not just like a
big bang now now we are in the world
scene and we manage at all but he saw it
as well as quantity sharma foreign
minister who united the the Russian
Foreign Minister the Ukrainian and the
French and at this crisis talk and maybe
it is an outcome that Putin is meeting
now the ukrainian President in Minsk
next week and so maybe this an outcome
German is trying to assume a bigger role
on the international floor I think it
would make it easier for German people
to do to accept this if it was all
embedded and this is what the German
government of course tries in a European
policy you know in going forward with
its partners this is what they're always
trying but until now what we saw as you
just mentioned before mr. Burke it was
that Germany fell behind its
responsibilities they let the jobs other
day they let others do the job so now
it's time to go for the source ability
among the European community within NATO
with maybe out sites were side by side
with the American government this would
be a good step I think national dreaming
i'm dreaming yeah European security and
defense policies is non-existent it's
all words words words and when the 28th
foreign ministers come together it
doesn't mean that they have a common
policy they use the same words but
that's all well I think we made it
abundantly clear that the decision any
decision on the stage is extremely
complicated thank you to my guess for a
very enlightening talk on this important
subject matter we will of course course
continue to follow this story as it
unfolds thank you out there for tuning
in and looking forward to seeing you
again next week for a new edition of cod
Riga